-Here he is, Blake Shelton.
Oh, my gosh, this is fantastic.
-Whoo! Jimmy!
-Nice to see you.
Nice to see you, buddy.
Where are you?
You got a lot of animals
back there.
-I'm in Oklahoma
at my place here.
And what did you say,
I got a lot of animals?
I do have a dog --
-Yeah, I saw --
-Betty, come here.
Come here.
-I saw a dog, aw.
-I got Betty here.
-That's a beautiful dog.
Oh, my -- oh, what a good dog.
-Oh, my God, your breath
smells like Jimmy.
-Oh, my gosh.
Who are you there with?
Who are you being safe with?
-We are quarantined
with a bunch of Stefanis.
I'm talking about
a pile of them.
It's me and a bunch of Stefanis.
My mom and stepdad live,
I don't know,
about 10 miles from here.
I haven't seen them
since the middle of March,
except for waving at them,
you know,
through the truck window.
And that's about it.
We haven't left.
-Yeah, it's kind of --
it's weird.
-I had to cancel my tour.
We were in Omaha, Nebraska.
And we were actually building
the production that day.
And finally just decided, that's
when pretty much the bottom
was falling out of all touring
and any live events.
And so we just cancelled,
and Gwen and I
immediately came here
and we have not left.
-What have you been doing
with all --
with your downtime?
It feels like the days go fast,
really, huh?
-Oh, my God, they do.
They go by so fast.
And a lot of us, because I black
out normally around
5:30 or 6:00 or something --
yeah, you like my hat,
by the way?
-Get closer, I can't see it.
-"I drank today."
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, that's not bad.
-That's pretty much all we do,
you know?
Gwen has learned
how to bake bread
really good, sourdough bread.
We're just -- literally it's
like, you know,
"Little House on the Prairie"
out here.
Like, she makes bread.
I've been building a fence
and gardening.
And we're pretty self-sufficient
out here.
As a matter of fact,
I don't know --
this interview,
I wanted to do it,
but we actually have a schedule
that we already
had lined out for today.
And I don't think
we can put it off any longer.
It's up to you, if you just want
to go ahead and start.
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Oh, my -- yay! Finally!
-We talked a lot about this.
Yeah, I'm going to be helping
Blake grow out his mullet.
So, you know, today we already
scheduled it was haircut day.
So, I have my clippers.
I got my attachments.
-Oh, my God.
-I got to get a haircut.
But go ahead with your questions
'cause you're a very good,
interesting interviewer.
And I don't want to miss...
-Oh, my God.
-...any of the good things
that you got to ask me.
-Thank gosh you took off
that camouflaged jacket
'cause I didn't --
I noticed
I didn't think
you had arms for a second.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
Are you gonna give him a mullet?
Please give him a mullet.
Please.
-Yeah.
-Blake, this is
really interesting --
I love seeing
Gwen cut your hair.
This is fantastic.
I love this.
Hey, are you guys, like --
do you guys give,
like,
give each other inspiration
on new music,
like, different music?
'Cause I know you have different
backgrounds musically.
Like, what have you --
what music are you
listening to, Gwen,
that you wouldn't have listened
to before Blake and vice versa?
-The music that Blake
turned me on to,
it's called country music.
Yeah, I hadn't really
listened to much of that
on my ska playlist.
But it's been fun learning
about country music,
and all the different --
He's literally an encyclopedia
jukebox, like a weirdo.
Like a weirdo
with the knowledge.
-Every country?
-This guy, he knows everything.
Like -- and we do games with him
where we'll
just, like,
play, like,
a little tiny taste of a song
to see if he will know it.
And we won't know what it is.
We'll just look it up on, like,
the Internet.
And he'll know it.
-The only time I've ever been
stumped on that,
is on your show, whenever
y'all played something --
like the "Welcome Back, Kotter"
version of "Hollaback Girl"
or whatever it was.
I didn't know --
-"Welcome back, Kotter" version?
You didn't even know your
girlfriend's song at the time.
-No, it was -- y'all played
some weird version of it
I never heard of before.
-I forgave him, though.
-Yeah.
-Blake, who --
what is the Conway Twitty song
where he sounds like Elvis?
-Oh, that's --
♪ People see us everywhere ♪
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
♪ -They think you really ♪
"It's Only Make Believe."
That's it.
-I love that song.
-It was a pop rock song.
That's what he had
his first success with.
And then later, he went country.
-I would love it if Gwen would
not come back
and just left you with
that haircut.
-What did he say?
-I said Conway started out rock
and pop and then went country
kind of like Gwen Stefani.
-Oh, yeah.
-Gwen has a country
hit right now.
We have a duet.
-Whoo!
-Who would have ever thought
Gwen Stefani on country radio?
-I know.
I love it.
I think it's so --
Do you love singing it, Gwen?
It comes -- It feels natural.
-It was one of those songs
that I was like,
"Wow, you just" --
these songs come to Blake.
They're so incredible.
And I was dreaming
that I could be on it.
We were working out together
in the gym.
And I was like, "Man, I wish
you'd put me on this one."
He actually turned
the song off and goes,
"Dang, I wish
I would put you on this one."
And then he did.
So here we are.
-Was it written as a duet
when it first --
-It wasn't. It was just --
No, it wasn't, was it?
-No, but what's crazy is that
one of the writers,
Shane, had sent me the song
to give to Blake.
Like, one of those,
he had my text
and he wanted me
to give it to him.
So it was a weird coincidence,
the whole thing.
-Are you getting him
into ska music at all?
-I tried.
I made him a ska playlist.
We were listening to a bunch
of reggae and UB-40.
We were building actually
a garden out here the other day.
We had, like, everybody on it,
pulling rocks and planting.
And we were listening to a lot
of that music that day.
So, did you like it?
-Yes.
-You got to get him to --
-We had Steel Pulse playing,
Jimmy.
That's a band you probably
never heard of.
But they're very popular
in the ska world.
-I know Steel Pulse.
My jam is "Ghost Town."
Is that Specials?
-Yeah.
-Blake, you'd like that one,
I think.
-Yeah, I do.
That's the one that goes...
[ Vocalizes ]
You're right.
I do love that song.
-Oh, my God, Gwen, I don't know
how you put up with this dude.
-Just learning, Jimmy,
but I already know that much.
-Can you come closer
to the camera
so I can see your haircut?
-Closer up.
-Yeah.
-Like shamish.
-How's the mullet? Is the mullet
getting long in the back?
-Not long enough, man.
You can get it longer.
But it's getting close.
I like those sides coming off.
This looks really good.
I've never seen you like this.
-You know, to be able to do this
to the greatest,
all-time greatest country star.
-Whoo!
♪ People see us everywhere ♪
-We're highlighting
a different charity
from everyone that's
on our show tonight.
-Yeah.
-And you chose MusiCares.
-So if you go to
grammy.com/musicares --
It's a long --
it's a lot of words.
I'll just put it up
on the screen.
-Put it up on the screen.
-Hey, really quickly,
can we talk about
"The Voice" while
you're getting your haircut?
-Let's do it.
No, what's scary is
we're going to have to do
"The Voice"
in some fashion like this,
because obviously, you know,
the live shows are coming up
here in just a matter of weeks.
And especially in L.A.,
we're not going to be
ready to, you know,
to have events again.
So it's going to be crazy.
We're going to have to coach
like this.
It's just going to have
to work out this way.
It's going to be nuts.
-Have you talked about it?
Have you -- do you have a plan?
-Yeah, a little bit.
I think they do.
I just kind of like --
Gwen's brother actually set up
this computer
and this interview
and everything for me today
because I clearly don't know
how to do this stuff.
So I think they have a plan,
and they're going to tell me
when to be at the computer.
And I -- you know,
I'll listen to them
I guess perform, and then
give them some pointers.
And I don't know.
This is a --
we're having to do things
that -- how does it look?
-I think it looks good.
-You look like
you're really handling
this whole quarantine well.
-Is that a joke about my weight?
That's a fat joke, isn't it,
Jimmy?
That's a fat joke, isn't it?
-No, it's not --
-You're right, though.
-It's not that at all.
It's just --
-Is that a good angle?
-Oh, my God.
No, no, no.
I'm -- Dude, you gone punk.
Your hair's punk.
Crazy, man.
That's what happens to a man.
-Love it.
-We get to see the real
Blake Shelton, finally.
-Hey, will you --
one last request,
will you put a J
and an F here
for Jimmy Fallon?
Please?
Please, please.
-Sure.
-I'm so happy to see
both of you guys,
and I got to tell everyone
watching at home,
"Nobody But You" is the song
from the album
"Fully Loaded: God's Country,"
but it is so beautiful,
and you guys do it so well,
and I actually --
I showed it
to my wife earlier today.
'Cause you guys just recorded
it for us, thank you.
But I loved it.
Great performance.
-We did, just for you.
-I know, my name --
I think you mentioned my name,
"Hey, Jimmy," I think you said.
-I'm literally putting
your initials
in my head right now, Jimmy.
I'm not kidding.
-See, these are why
these shows are fun
because you would never
do this in real life.
-She just said they're not
showing up very well
because of the gray.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no, that looks terrible.
-Blake, get right in there.
Get real close
so I can really see it.
Yeah.
-There's the F,
and here's the J.
-Oh, my gosh.
Dude, you are so "Tiger King"
right now, you have no idea.
[ Laughter ]
I love you guys,
and stay safe, okay?
-We love you.
Thanks for having us
on "The Tonight Show" today.
-I love you guys.
"The Tonight Show" today.
Come back, can't wait to see you
in person again.
I miss you, guys.
-Love you, buddy.
-Thank you, guys. Thank you.
-See ya.